nouvelle donne une référence au new deal
cette politique menée par le président
américain franklin roosevelt face à la
crise de 1929 et pour les représentants
yvelinois de ce mouvement
la priorité comme dans les années 30
c'est la lutte contre le chômage
la proposition forte de nouvelles donnes
les livres de pierre larrouturou
c'est sur le partage du travail avec des
solutions pragmatiques expliqué validé
par des économistes deuxième point cela
transit sur l'écologie cinq candidats
soutiendront ses propositions dans les
yvelines comme gilles pons le voit dans
la 2e circonscription michel lavezzari
dans la 3e ou encore marie thérèse
manteau ni dans la dixième
fonctionnaires de l'éducation nationale
cette dernière a adhéré au mouvement en
elle se présente avec une idée de son
rôle de député considère que la mission
de député c'est voter des lois au niveau
du national mais c'est aussi à présent
dans une circonscription et être
vraiment à l'écouté des personnes pour
justement faire remonter est vraiment
être sur le terrain pour ce que de toute
façon on peut pas faire les choses à
distance comme ça voilà il faut vraiment
entendre ce que ce que les gens à ont à
dire pour pouvoir penser après et faire
des propositions concrètes qui tienne la
route lors de la présidentielle nouvelle
donne a appelé sur un ton humoristique à
une candidature benoît hamon
pour ce scrutin législatif sur le
territoire yvelinois il n'y aura pas de
candidature pour le mouvement dans
plusieurs circonscriptions à la 11e
circonscription on va laisser benoît
hamon défendre ses idées par exemple là
c'est clair
benoît hamon dans sa candidature à la
présidentielle à exprimer des idées très
proches des nôtres donc on va pas les
chercher un croche-pied je retrouve plus
de 80% des idées de nouvelles donnes non
je peux me sentir proche du programme de
france insoumise après du fonctionnement
du mode de discours de la façon d'être
de françoise ou me gêne un peu plus de
mal face à la situation du parti
socialiste et à la modification du
système partisan
le mouvement de pierre larrouturou veut
participer à la recomposition politique
pour engendrer une nouvelle donne dans
l'histoire de la gauche française